depuis aujourd'hui le monde compte un
état de plus le monténégro à voter pour
son indépendance vis-à-vis de la serbie
nous verrons dans un instant les
réactions de la population et les
conséquences de ce référendum
mais auparavant gros plan sur ce pays
qui avait perdu son indépendance après
la première guerre mondiale
alexandra marie en français monténégro
signifie la montagne noire
cet ancien royaume tient son nom des
forêts qui recouvrent plus de la moitié
de son territoire soit treize mille huit
cents kilomètres carrés à peine plus
grand que l'île de france
l'indépendance du pays signe la fin de
la yougoslavie
les autres états s'était déjà séparé de
la serbie durant les guerres des années
90 si aujourd'hui un nouvel état
apparaît sur la carte les 650 milles
monténégrins était déjà de fait
indépendant de belgrade
pour preuve leur monnaie n'est autre que
l'euro ce micro état est résolument
tournée vers l'europe
aujourd'hui les investissements
étrangers affluent dans la capitale
podgorica et le pays compte beaucoup sur
le potentiel touristique de son littoral
encore à peine exploiter